i absolutely think makeup transcends
gender it can change you into whoever
you want to be
i love that little switch like i put on
a lash and everyone's minds explode
it's hilarious it's like magic about it
when it's used in a way
to become it's like a metamorphosis you
can
be somebody who's more confident or like
a superhero anytime i'm having a bad day
put makeup on the day is already better
i definitely have been putting on makeup
my whole life i wanted to wear
eyeliner when i was in third grade i
would rate my mom's bathroom
i didn't know how to use any of the
products i would put in makeup all over
myself
when i was 14 i was going in on youtube
videos i would watch
a 18 hour makeup tutorial i would just
sit there and i'm like okay i'm gonna do
this tomorrow
beauty and makeup were non-existent
jonathan would hate this i used to shave
my face with just
a razor and water
[Music]
when i went to school i wasn't allowed
to wear makeup i had to be kind of
neutral
especially being transgender i couldn't
wait for the day that i could finally
put on makeup and experiment with it and
go out with it
it was a place that you could play and
figure out what feels authentic
to me that natural side that feels
ethereal and soft and then there's like
the instagram face beat glam of just
like
bad [ __ ] territory being able to be
free and daring with the makeup that you
wear
helps you find out who you are and
express yourself the best that you can
starting my transition i use drag makeup
as kind of a
mask so i was kind of so scared to play
with femininity i didn't really want to
look too
pretty i wanted to look as clown and
crazy as possible at all times but then
when i experimented on the show
i kind of was like oh look gorgeous hell
so now i'm definitely way more
down to experiment with looking really
feminine
the queer community took that under
their belt very early because it gave
them a way to express themselves in
every
color and light and let the world know
who they were put a little glitter
and you just feel so much more glam so
much more powerful
for some people it is what makes them
want to explore
it's a way of saying gender doesn't
matter
it's a form of expression being a truer
version of yourself and sometimes it
doesn't even have to be that like you
can be a character
if you're in drag you're the most
powerful thing in the entire room